hey guys George camel here with the
all-new Dave Ramsey show app now you can
listen and watch like never before on
your device wherever you are
Radio out of whack give it a smash PC on
the fritz smash it to bits miss the show
check out past episodes right in the app
it's the Dave Ramsey show not that far
back
customize your highlights to catch all
your favorite moments like dead free
screams
and Dave Rance you unethical slime balls
but wait there's more
you can also see what's coming up next
on the show plus you can start right
where you left off like this love your
work keep it up we've got little
hipsters with their growth all stunted
and yes we're on Android too you could
download today you can get it for the
low low price those zero dollars
download in the next 30 minutes and it's
twice as free but that's not all you can
also use it to walk the dog cover your
bald spots call for help in case of
emergencies I've been dead and I can't
get out you just have to reach a moment
where you say I've had it give your car
a mirror-like Senate sick of paper
towels the Dave Ramsey show app holds a
tee times water water slice the tomato
with ninja-like precision make a tasty
smoothie throw it in the dishwasher with
the Dave Ramsey show app you'll have
Street free plates every time but don't
take it from me listen to this random
man or woman this is the best up I've
ever seen in my life
don't delay download today and you'll
receive your very own Dave Ramsey chia
pet here's how to order
watch the live stream on the Dave Ramsey
show app check out past episodes
customize all your favorite moments and
see what's coming up pause/resume and
scrolling through the show comes
standard download the Dave Ramsey show
app today on the Apple App Store or
Google Play
[Music]